hello everyone so super nervous super
excited though to present on recording
presentations using OBS and YouTube it's
a cool way to put yourself on YouTube
it's a cool way to educate others and
kind of gonna do that now to show
everyone from start to finish to install
to YouTube how to do OBS and take that
recording and put on YouTube ooh I'm
getting ahead of myself
that's for later go ahead and exit out
of that and so I have instructions
actually on how to get started I want to
go over some system requirements for OBS
this is OBS setup and settings and so
OBS is available on Windows Mac and
Linux it's amazing it's on all three it
works well on all three
it does require DirectX 10 compatible
integrated graphics and so it's a it's a
more modern CPU type thing and so like
that basically is like Intel i5 2000
series or higher I uses open GPL on
Linux and so I had an old laptop
actually couldn't use because it was a
Core 2 Duo laptop and it's just too old
and so it's almost kind of it's not
really a I use it for open source
development so I still use it but this
laptop does OBS quite well new like a
little Jo system recommendations it's
hard to find hard specific requirements
for OBS online but basically news better
than old kind of a given gaming or
business laptop it's generally better
because of the heatsinks an ultrabook
and so this is ultrabook so if i were to
play you know battlefield one and do OBS
at the same time this one's gonna be
screaming just as it tries to cool it
down which is really kind of distracting
for the microphone so if you have a
gaming laptop or business laptop it's
better but for what I'm doing it's gonna
be fine
because I'm just doing a presentation
and so mo Ram mo better and so I got a
little picture of a ram there if you can
see it it is optimized for Windows and
so if you're on Windows you're in luck
there's a lot of streamers online a lot
of people recording content online
windows and you get quite a bit less CPU
usage on windows and linux is getting
better everyday and it's developed for
all of them so pre setup you want to
change your resolution in 1920 by 1080
or 1280 by 720 basically the HD
resolutions the reason I say that I'm
currently on 720 this is a 4k monitor on
this laptop and for OBS to have to scale
from 4k to 1080i is a little bit too
intensive for it and so the cpu unless
you're on a gaming laptop or a business
laptop that has a you know like a good
heatsink then it's it's gonna struggle a
little bit so I like 720 because if
you're doing a presentation if you're if
you're showing windows like I'm gonna be
showing you they're gonna be easier to
see so the first thing we need to do is
download OBS you can do this live guys
dun-dun-duh click on windows and so
here's that this is a 64-bit installer
which is what you want to do most of the
time here's 32-bit we're going to do
this 64 it's gonna download it oh that's
not too bad but I'm gonna cancel it on
my sheet I already have a OBS downloaded
should right there yes alright so
missing components what those components
are talking about real quick is it once
you have the Visual Studio C C++ library
included and so if you don't already
have that installed I uninstalled it
before the presentation
then it will trigger that message so
it's going to install them so that
should be pretty quick didn't you click
here there we go that's a lot faster
it's much smaller open that bad boy up
and if you've already been using a
business might sound a little bit too
involved but I do want to have basically
a presentation that covers the whole
aspect of it so setup successful all
right so I'm gonna I think I'm gonna run
the exit again there we go
I agree we're gonna install out to
program files over your studio browser
source that's a good one to have all
right let's just go ahead and stall it
so basically it's next next next alright
we're gonna launch OBS studio okay we're
in ooh
I kept all my settings okay hold on give
me one second and I'm going to actually
projects Jo app data roaming and
actually start completely fresh here for
the benefits of learning I take one
second so quit out of OBS delete my this
isn't Jo app data roaming
my name is Jo by the way I think we
covered that all right and so open up
OBS studio again alright and now we're
starting fresh and so here's the License
Agreement saying it has the GNU general
public license which is a very good
thing you're over that a little later
that means it's open source anyone can
contribute to it alright and then it
pops up would you like to run the auto
configuration wizard yes I would it's
kind of a sanity check hit yes and so it
says optimized for streaming recording
and secondary that's a if you are gonna
be streaming that's a good way to do
that if you do through this option see
if I go next yeah it's gonna want you to
enter your stream key you can change
your streaming service here we're not
gonna go into that we're just gonna do
optimize for recording I will not be
streaming and you can always run the
wizard again alright
and so the base canvas resolution if I
was on 1080p I'd want to select 1080p
from here since I am on 720p then I want
to use 720 as my canvas the canvas is
basically where you're going to put all
of your
webcam and Twitter information for
example so frames per second I go a
30-30 is plenty for a demonstration 30
is plenty for twitch if you want to
stream to twitch 60 is kind of a little
extreme it requires a lot more
processing it also requires a lot more
bandwidth if you're streaming I do 30
next apply settings and we're almost
good to go so we did we installed visual
studio basically OBS redirect us to
their site we downloaded the file we
installed it we restarted the
installation that worked alright one
thing I do want to point out is so once
you start working with OBS you may
notice things are not working correctly
this is a quick this is a quick kind of
like gotcha
if you have Nvidia graphics on your card
you might need to check your settings
and we're gonna go through that real
quick so I'm gonna hit the Windows key
do control panel I'm gonna go to
hardware and sound and then nvidia
control panel and so once this pops up
it's gonna allow me to go over to
program settings over here and show
automatically pull it up since I'm using
it yep and so we're the open broadcaster
software is open and sometimes it's set
to a high performance in video processor
we want to make sure it's not integrated
graphics and that's all you got to do i
was already set to integrate graphics
i'll go ahead and apply alright we're
good and that'll make sure everything
runs smoothly alright so let's see
what's next we did the auto
configuration wizard by the way to get
back to that just go to tools auto auto
configuration wizard and you can set up
streaming later they do have auto
configuration wizard and thankfully they
do because OBS settings can get intense
very intense alright so we set the
canvas we've set 30 frames per second we
need to set the record path I do
recommend that to do that you go to file
settings and we go down to
outputs and then we do recording path
and it set to Joe or see users Joe
videos that's good Scott so I'm gonna
leave it but it's good to do that just
make sure the videos are going to where
you expect hello hello just getting
started
we basically installed OBS at this point
and doing very basic settings alright
and so let's add a background I add a
background just so you have a good
contrast so here we have a scene the
default scene name is scene and we want
to start adding sources oh I need to
resize this so we can see it better
alright and so here are the sources we
want to add a new source and that new
source is gonna be image let's go to
naina oh let's go it's good the name
things so we're gonna name this
background and that way the source has a
name that makes sense my browse for
background go to OBS I have this cool
little circuit board background I'm
gonna click OK and oh you can see that
it's not scaled well and so the simple
way to get that because this is a 1080p
image or greater I think and you can
actually Smoove it like that little
laborious but uh that's what I'm
basically gonna do right there so that's
the new background alright and so we
want to add a webcam get into the Juicy
Juice and so this is what the advantage
of OBS over all over over other screen
recording software you actually do the
webcam so we're do video capture device
and we're gonna call this internal
webcam awesome there we go hello how
would he do add that in there that's
huge I'm gonna scale down and do it the
same way I did that pop it over here and
bam this works in a pinch I don't
recommend it
I do recommend getting a dedicated
webcam and that's what this is here I
don't know if I can show here I might
show a better but there you go I can do
that song
so this is a so this is a logitech
webcam don't remember the model number
but it basically it's like a transformer
oh you can like unfold it turn it around
and that has like a little hook here
it's kind of like the PlayStation camera
you've ever seen those and then it just
basically hooks onto the monitor like
that I'm gonna cover the existing webcam
we're no longer gonna use it what I
really like about these is kind of
all-in-one streaming
booster and the main advantage for me is
that it puts the microphone further away
from the fan on the computer further
away from the keyboard on the computer
and it makes it makes for clearer audio
the picture I think is a little bit
better but it depends on your computer
but if you have an older computer it
definitely can help and so I've already
plug it in but windows would normally be
like installing drivers and once that's
done we're gonna remove this webcam and
that and the webcam disappeared be just
because I put the other webcam on top of
it so we're gonna do video capture
device again we're gonna call this a
logitech webcam there you go Bama - BAM
there I am adjust the camera bit my
handsome devil
all right click OK and this looks kind
of boring
honestly the square has been done square
has been done and so I'm gonna guess
this is a 4 by 3 ratio and we're gonna
create our first mask guys OBS is all
about masks and so I think that's the
next step Creighton add a mask
so here's better you better to use a
dedicated web camera mic let's let's
make a mask and so I'm just gonna jump
right into it it's kind of hard to
explain but masking is basically setting
up an image to allow you to crop another
image to almost any shape and so we're
gonna go straight to paint be better use
Photoshop can create a anything like
that over
paint but I love paint you know goes
back to the windows 95 or was it 98 I
don't remember all right so let's go and
resize it I'm gonna do pixels I'm gonna
do 640 by 480 Oh
oh yeah I maintain aspect ratio let's
get out of there get out of there
640 480 all right and then I'm gonna
click back on maintain aspect ratio no
god I had a click okay live
demonstration okay I recommend going
bigger and the reason so now sit back 2%
I'm gonna go 200% make it bigger that's
because the pixels are gonna be sharper
here in a second let me make it a lot
smaller by going down to the zoom over
here alright and so we're gonna do
something cute we're gonna do a little
played around with this I really like
paint because you have these free shapes
here say free everything should be free
button so here we got this shape and I
am going to set it to solid fill outline
no outline we don't want my outline and
then we're gonna take the shape we're
gonna drag it it should be white yeah
it's why and then I'm just gonna go
ahead and fill the screen with it okay
and make sure it's centered I also want
to make sure it's kind of a circle okay
good enough definition had done right
there
I'm gonna save as it's gonna be a PNG
spoil alert another mask up there
alright
so PNG and we're gonna call it Oh bubble
mask oh yes no what is that what is this
thought-bubble
be more specific I thought bubble
I'm in the weeds it's good all the way
it's alright save okay and so I got the
logitech webcam here and we want to
apply that mask and so what I'm gonna do
is I'm a right-click on this I'm gonna
go to filters and and add us at these
resolutions you're fighting with OBS a
little bit on what the windows are doing
so I'm gonna move this down you'll see
me do this a lot so that gives me access
to edit filters I'm gonna add a filter
and we want to do image mask blend we're
going to call this thought-bubble
just so we know what it is okay we're
there alright we want to select the path
of the mask brows already have a set up
it's in this OBS folder right here that
I set up click it and bada-bing
bada-boom web cam is a thought bubble
now all right
so also it's pretty good right now I
wanted to show you a little trick and
this I think I didn't mark this down so
you can crop and pad which is another
filter you can apply to zoom the webcam
image so what do you do with webcam
sometimes it'll appear far away
especially on ones built into the
computer so we shouldn't do that right
now or do crop pad pretty easy I'm gonna
call this zoom instead of crop pad so we
know what it's doing alright and this is
just simply adding numbers to all of
them and so I'm gonna do 15 15 15 15 oh
no I got some clipping up here that's
not great so the more numbers you do the
more zooms so we all I have to do is
move zoom above this and then we have a
perfectly zoomed webcam image it doesn't
look like we need zoom we're gonna get
rid of it
close that alright and so I'm a big fan
of making sure contrasts are great the
contrast around the rim is not very good
we're gonna make a border and we're
gonna make a border using the same mask
we just used so we're gonna add an image
we're going to call this webcam border
and this is kind of a hacky way to do it
but we'll do it real quick put the
thought-bubble back in there
awesome click ok alright and then we
need to apply some filters to this to
make it just a solid white circle so
filters oh yeah scroll down go back up
and then we're going to apply the color
key filter so do this color key there
you go
I couldn aim that better but anyways do
a custom color gonna do black alright
now we just have a basically a white box
in the same shape I'm gonna change the
color just a little bit wrong color
forgot about that okay I want to change
the color of it just a little bit
because there's gonna be a white
presentation so it's just gonna
disappear so I'm gonna do color
correction I think I want to do that
afterwards so I moved it up select color
gray alright and then it's it oh yeah
okay Creighton's yeah so it color
correction needs to be below so we're
making a little bit more gray actually
using saturation here think it'll get it
close to the color it says yeah anyways
now all we're gonna do is not that not
that at all so that'll happen a lot and
how I get around that is I will lock it
down your lock down now you can't move
all right and this is just kind of a
cheeky way to do a border but it allows
you to kind of someone put the webcam
above it and and then I want to link
these together so I'm gonna click this
click this move this up move it there
I'm gonna Lock these together by
right-clicking
and it where's it at group selected
items and now we have a webcam and a
border I think it likes makes it look
more professional for sure
all right move it on so the next step I
notice a little bit of aureus guys but
it does help add a little
professionalism and it kind of shows you
how to use masks and some other key
elements we're gonna create some Twitter
art let's add that I'm gonna do an image
first we're gonna call it Twitter logo I
got this logo off to Twitter site you
can download assets from them this is
the round social media icon open that
alright pretty big we're gonna make a
smaller lot smaller oh that big spit put
it down here alright and then we're
gonna make a my Twitter tag is at Joe
Matthews okay see we're gonna do that
now and this is this next step so we're
gonna we're gonna add text we're gonna
change the font size to be huge and that
way we get sharper edges and then we'll
scale it down then we're gonna add
outline which is really only available
in windows I try testing it and it might
work in on Mac but it doesn't work on
Linux yet you might need to add
something to it to make it work to
explain what's going on there I'm just
gonna call this at Joe Matthews okay see
I think I spelled that right I'm also
gonna copy that I'm about to type it
again I've got text select fonts I'm
just gonna do 72 so it makes it sharper
all right I think Ariel's fine go fancy
if you want and so don't need to change
anything here I think the color is fine
for right now the background color I
think that's fine it's it's just clear
and so what we want is a line that go
back was it left okay
outlying we're gonna click that and then
we're gonna change the color I need to
kind of find the Twitter logo so we're
gonna change the outline color and we're
gonna make it the same as the Twitter
logo so how I did that again as I select
color on outlines to outline island
color select color pick color and then I
just do it again
let's hover over the Twitter kinda like
right in the middle bada-bing bada-boom
and then so here it is it doesn't look
that great so let's increase the outline
let's do let's do 5 nope let's do more
let's go more 30 30 well not let me do
Ripoff 20 is the highest 20 is enough
though that looks good
kinda looks like a red bubble sticker
you ever bought those I gave that
analogy earlier crickets I like red
bubble all right so we're gonna resize
this thought of being about a boom this
will look a lot sharper on YouTube
that's scaling down the image and then
I'm hitting control so it's wanted to
snap this thing so it'll snap it snap
everywhere but I want it to be in the
middle of the Twitter logo so i'ma hold
ctrl and kind of wing it and then I'm
gonna join these two together so how I
do that is you can either do it here or
on the screen itself it ctrl on both of
them so like control click control click
right click and then already lost it
should I not put these together root
let's try it over here go to group
selected items okay I guess you have to
do it right now these are together and
now you can scale them they'll scale
together it's your own personal logo you
could make this in in in and
Photoshop and Krita and have a
transparent background have the same
effect this is just kind of a way to do
it in text and also to show you how text
works
anyways so I think we're about done we
need to add one more source which is the
big one
which is to record the screen and so we
don't need to hide the background it's
gonna be in memory anyway so we're just
gonna do plus and then we're going to do
display capture I did want to point out
one one other capture which is a good
one
windows capture let's go over that first
we're not gonna use it so windows
capture I'm gonna call it Chrome only
and this is a good way to kind of keep
your privacy you know I like I think I
closed everything before it came up here
but if you're all tabbing and there's
like messaging conversations up or
whatever then they're gonna see it but
this can be the window only that you're
looking at so do Chrome only and then
that looks like a lot of gobbly so
we need to find chrome eventually found
it here and sometimes you'll see more
than one dot X II look for the one that
has the tile you want
oh no why is that not working I know I'm
gonna have to troubleshoot that later oh
well let me check let me check the
setting settings I don't think this will
have anything to do with it okay so this
so I'll show you where I went with the
file settings what's the output and here
you have it encoder settings so this is
under recording an encoder this actually
needs to be software it actually can be
Hardware in ii-v ii-v ENC not a lot of
gamers use that it's it's probably 10 20
% faster on your computer but I've got
an error that I needed to update the
drivers and so I'm just gonna use
software and I don't have an OK button
so much scroll it down click apply click
OK I don't know if that's why I'm not
seeing that so let me try getting the
nervous
get rid of Chrome only I'm gonna just do
straight to display captured that's how
you would capture just one window
hopefully this works
every when oh no it's the inception
inception and so this is kind of most
awful thing to see and you'll see it a
lot in almost every almost every OBS
like if someone switches back to OBS
while they're streaming you'll see this
it's kind of sorrentine but it's just
showing a mirror effect because it is
recording within recording so we just
click OK really annoying want to get out
of here as soon as we can what happened
to all our stuff it's actually this
floated the window to the top and so we
need them on the sources.list move this
down so click the down arrow and stuff
starts popping back up Oh too far
alright
is that exciting guys so far so good
alright so we'll get into the meat and
potatoes a little bit and so the
presentation itself is go full on we're
going to setup OBS which we just just
did we're gonna record a presentation
which is gonna be pretty short and then
we're up load that to youtube and I
might do another talk later where I go
advanced OBS stuff as I learn more but
we do have some bonus things at the end
to keep in mind not going to do the
browser one but basically we're gonna do
or we are gonna add Spotify so we're
gonna add album art to OBS I'm gonna
show you how to do that using masks
getting back to the good stuff and so
I'm gonna start the recording and no
errors which is good and so it shows
stop recording now and so we're gonna go
back to Chrome did not mean it closed it
all the way down I don't think go back
to my slides here's the presentation you
saw before it's a little bit
tongue-in-cheek this is kind of meant to
be fast and the main content of what
you're learning is supposed to be in the
actual demonstration itself and so here
we go
recording presentations using OBS and
YouTube and so what is OBS
OBS stands for open broadcaster software
it's created by Hugh Jim Bailey and many
contributors a lot of people have helped
out on this the first release was in
September 2012
there's presets for streaming to twitch
YouTube Instagram Facebook and others
it's open source software so that means
anyone can contribute to it anyone can
make it better it's probably going to be
free forever and it's a license to Anu
GPL v2 that's a general public license
and that means that if anyone improves
it they have to contribute the code back
to the main repository and make that
code available they don't have to
contribute back they have to make it
available so it's a really good thing as
community driven software and it is the
number one software for streaming it's
also very popular for recording screens
because of the ability to add webcams
and control audio and just the amount of
settings you can do you can control
everything on it I was telling other
people if you can see it on your
computer you can put it on your stream
so that alternatives to OBS little trail
move here they probably have 99 percent
market share and they don't charge a
dime and so I wouldn't recommend using
anything else I'm not gonna tell you to
use anything else I'm gonna mention
names that's because that's how much I
love OBS I showed you a little bit with
masks you can do a lot with masks and
then you can do a lot with browser
integration too that's how you get the
magical pop pop up on the screens when
you're watching twitch well won't get to
that but I will show you how to use mass
to get Spotify on there using a non
copyrighted music of course right
Kimberly right alright and so the actual
did like this is going on YouTube but
this is going on YouTube after what
we're actually recording right now so
it's a little bit of recording inception
so my detailed OBS setup presentation
for OBS oh man I repeated
yes twice as embarrassing it's coming
soon to YouTube the presentation is
actually created right now during that
presentation from the future that's a
little hard to explain but everything
you're seeing me doing right now is
gonna be the second video in the series
we're about to upload the first which is
this presentation that I hit start
recording on I created a little go for
part two because like Back to the Future
Marty McFly is visiting himself at the
dance it's pretty cool so what is
YouTube I know what YouTube is everyone
saying why is YouTube important you know
but why record presentations why add
content for me personally it's kind of a
personal thing YouTube's been very
powerful for me I've learned Excel I've
learned programming learned a lot of
things that you expect me to learn in my
profession but also I learned how to
stain concrete on my new house I learned
how to repair a leaky bathtub I don't
think I can do that I learned how to
paint a house the right way you actually
have to clean it with soap that way the
paint doesn't peel off it's on there
like it's on there are cornell and etc
I've learned a lot of things I don't
necessarily think I could do better
videos than that what I can do is do
programming videos I can do OBS videos
and this is kind of my first video to
YouTube promote yourself you know show
what you've what you're good at what
you've made you know show your
communication skills to your new
employer show show what you're worth to
a little bit give back it's the kind of
thing it's like I can I can do I can't
do a lot of videos but I can do it OBS
video and also learn better so this is
kind of like the last minute ad here but
it but it's important me me doing this
like I would consider myself like you
know I can mid-tier you know wizard as
far as OBS goes I think I could figure
out a lot of things using masks and
using web to get almost anything to work
but just making this presentation I had
to kind of reclassify some conceptions I
had some misconceptions things didn't
work as I expected into so putting this
all together I learned OBS better and so
putting a presentation together alone
may help you learn it better and of
course since this is being seen on
YouTube like comment and subscribe
please
alright that's the last slide from there
I'm gonna go and click back off its stop
recording
alright and so what's next so we
recorded we click the start recording
button do the presentation click the
stop recording button and wanted to add
one more thing because I'm all about
being transparent about hang-ups okay
let's get rid of this inception thing
going on there it's really trippy
alright so if we go to settings and so
if you try to do start present or start
recording and you get an error the error
might be caused by what I checked
earlier so if you go to out outputs go
to encoder you might try software
encoder cuz the error might be about in
need east
what is I say in V and C alright so
what's the next step
alright upload it to YouTube sounds
reasonable
alright let me close this out I'm gonna
go to youtube.com and I did a teaser
video before actually did a lot of
teaser videos only one got chosen I'm
gonna my channel I'm very new to YouTube
and uploading videos so I just do
YouTube studio over here on the right
there's probably people in here that are
masters at YouTube and let's talk its
connect and then dashboard no videos
plus
uploads' oh man
so before I just had a big ol fat upload
new video anyone wants to bail me out
how do I upload a new video
we're here let's do it
yes the icon was obvious all right
and so I'm gonna go nope I'm gonna do
private that's because we need to trim
it and so I set it to go to videos
oh so many videos no sort by date real
quick
237 it's all right open all right title
[Music]
so recording presentations with OBS and
I'll do a regular on YouTube
part 1 all right
here I give an introduction to YouTube
all right to OBS and part two oh I think
it's done
oh processing 95 okay I'm gonna go ahead
and click done
alright so return to YouTube studio beta
okay I want to go to click on one of my
videos being about a boom there we go
click on this there we go editor so
editor allow you to trim the beginning
in the end of a video and we're gonna do
that to make this a little bit more
professional and here you can zoom to
get more of a timeline so you can
fine-tune it a little better so right oh
we have to trim so it's hid trim right
about here I think okay and then it
automatically trim it up in here 22
scroll
okay
all right trim split cancel I would
expect me to do a preview
oh there goes it stop okay why is this
not working anyone know any
professionals Oh cuz I didn't do
anything
okay I swear I did okay I think that's
about good right there
preview
and we're gonna listen to this I'm
joking so what is party reporting
reporting reporting presentations using
the OBS in YouTube
porting presentations using OBS inside
looks good so what is open broadcaster
software okay so that's gonna cook and
that is basically how to do all of what
I promised to do on that presentation
and so with that you can record almost
anything you could play a video in the
background record yourself commentating
on that a lot of stuff you can do
including gaming and so if you want to
do gaming the only real difference is
you plug in a twitch key into OBS
settings go through that and go through
that the getting started it's not
tutorial but a section at the twitch key
that's almost concludes my presentation
I wanted to show you Spotify I'll need
to show you using browser stuff later
and so browser stuff is the real
powerful stuff but one thing I ran into
is telling some as they walked into the
walked into the presentation here I
wanted to be a counter-strike star you
know I wanted to kill nubs on the
Internet's and do it on Twitch so I
learned a lot of OBS to do good
production value for that and one of the
things I really wanted was to add a
Spotify like album art and song playing
to the stream I'm sure there's ways to
do that a very hacky using api's and
stuff like that but I did find a way to
use you know along the principles if you
can see it you can add it and so I
created a mask for Spotify
and so well not that mask so if I open
up Spotify here alright and one thing I
did to try to find good music to play
because if you play music just as a
normal user
they will mute your entire broadcast
that's recorded and and also I think
you're held to a higher standard if your
educational source they might send you a
message be like don't do that and so
they're basically looking for
copyrighted music I think it's very much
a slap on the wrist now but it's always
good to just not mess with it and so I
type in twitch up in here
and that brings up this profile I don't
know if it's official or not but it does
have I've seen this before then the
nocopyrightsounds which is a group that
puts out music for people and anyone can
play it and so most of the album arts
the same which is unfortunate it's even
find one that's different I don't think
it's actually changing anyway so let's
try to Starbound I think they're all the
same
oh there's one yeah okay and so I wanted
to show you the changing of our work so
I wanted to basically get this out of
Spotify and put it into my into my
twitch or into OBS you can do this
during a presentation if you wanted to
that you just record not stream and so
lose this chill music playing in the
background turn down
[Music]
all right and so what we're gonna do is
we're actually going to use a mask and
so hopefully it's a work it was a little
finicky earlier when do window capture
again we're name this Spotify
we're gonna go down and shoes Spotify
there we go
Lars in over I think that's a song
that's playing do that
yeah up so I want to grab this and
so what actually did add that I'm just
gonna pop over it is 720p so it takes up
the whole screen and so it's up here at
the top on the new filters
I like EDM very distracting
and so we're gonna add a filter or add a
mask again just like we did for the
webcam alright just show you what this
mask is I made this in paint as well to
make sure I can do it basically I took a
screen shot being shot and then paint
I'm not gonna actually do the mask paste
this in here and basically I added a
white box said I'm not gonna do it but
here it goes and then I just went over
it with the white box all right
and then I colored all this black to
show you real quick how that happened
but I did sumed in to try to make it
picks appropriate like angular panel
I colored everything black around it so
just double click make sure that's not
really black that sort of thing and then
you just take this black thing and I
said I was gonna do it but I'm actually
doing all right
so
oh my gosh I clicks you
anyways you change it to black as the
the box and you just highlight it all to
get it all out of there you also have to
remove this bottom bar because it does
not include the no vs so all I did was
do is drag that up there you go think of
all this black and that turns into it uh
this is the 720p basically OBS mask for
Spotify activated drags on me and so we
go Brown like that and then it all he
gets the album artwork close and we go
dragged out to the side over here and
just to show you I'm gonna use my
keyboard to change the album and so if I
do we don't have to function the next
song
it changes the album and it shows who's
playing below and that'll look a lot
sharper on stream alright
so did I close my presentation and so
that I think concludes my presentation
on how to use OBS to record your
presentation and upload it to YouTube
I'd like to go more in depth on certain
topics it gets pretty technical at some
point I'd be very curious to hear what
you all think you can do Joe Matthews
okay see on Twitter let me know what you
what you'd like to try and I can maybe
figure it out with you other than that
any questions
can people share filters so you're
talking about taking like that Spotify
and kind of exporting that and so one
way to do that and this is new
I believe it's new or else I missed it
the first time is if I wanted to extract
all this I'm kind of doing this live
with you because I just found out about
it if you do tools but if you do tools
and then you do a tool scene area scene
collection and then we have a untitled
can I do save as I can't do say why is
it untitled if you can't save it I guess
you could do new and then you name it
anyway so I'm on untitled right now I do
export and then I put that anywhere I
want to put at OBS already did it right
here I can call this presentation scenes
okay save let's go see what that looks
like though presentation scenes open
with code alright and so that's what
this looks like
it looks very editable which is amazing
and so I'm pretty sure if you were to
send this to a friend all they would
have to do is have all the files that
are in the same folder I might need to I
don't know you'd have to you'd have to
check it out yeah so it's hard coding
this and so you'd have to go through and
kind of change it but it's more of a
backup for yourself and these and these
OBS profiles are kind of what makes
streamers money so there's not much
sharing going on in general but as far
as I've seen but I guess that is an
awesome new feature because that wasn't
possible it might have been in settings
like deep buried in I just don't know
where it was but that export options
there and you can back that up because
you can spend hours days doing that and
then the OBS might crap out on you one
day but it's nice to have that backup
it's never ever deleted a config file on
me though unlike other broadcasting so
I've heard about and so any was that did
I answer your question all right anyone
else Oh tough question the best I
understand it and if anyone is like an
engineer raise your hand
hurry hurry damn it's a video bitrate I
know that it's 3,000 recommended by
twitch for 1080p
I think it's 2,000 or 2200 for 720p and
so it's currently set at 25 which would
be a great 720p stream the best I know
it uses FLV but I did not look that up
let's look up what that means it's flash
live video LV format and what this
allows what this allows is twitch to get
your content and also we recorded it
it's the same format we recorded and
uploaded YouTube it allows twitch to get
your contact content without letting it
finish recording and so it's getting it
at a twenty five hundred bit rate and
and it's allowing everyone to view that
at the same moment it's twitch servers
everyone can access your content it's
very kind of efficient way to to get
that out there and so I do know the
recommended what if this is the same one
that stands for flash flash video all
right
FL okay yeah the L is the F L and flash
but twitch recommended that rate I will
speak from personal experience do not
cheap out on a router don't do it
get the I got the the best of the best
I don't like it's like advertisement I
think it's 3200
this boy is mean it is I would consider
the best they have a one that's set up
just for Xbox but I would consider this
one the best router you can buy I got it
for 150 refurbished from Walmart you can
put open-source software on it to make
it do whatever you want
and I wouldn't recommend that because
well I would recommend it you just might
not have a router for a while but it's
really it's a but yeah so he uses open
wrt for that and this will help your
stream the most it handles the bitrate
and make sure you don't do packet losses
during that bitrate when you're
transferring it I've had a lot of issues
on Twitch
I traced the cable back and it was the
router and I hate to say just buy more
money but spend more money but as long
as we're in our current standard AC
standard I guess for Wi-Fi this is gonna
be their best router until we move to
something new question oh yeah yeah
that's for sure but even if you do that
that's a good point repeat the question
oh man Thank You Austin the question was
the question before that was I think
just general questions about explaining
bitrate I'm not an engineer I don't know
the second question was could you not
just connect directly in the router and
that is correct and and so I got a
little bit off on a tangent you're right
there I love I love open wrt I kind of
sprung off on that some routers have 100
megabyte connections and some have
gigabit connections and even if you have
gigabit it's still being processed and
so the more memory that that router has
a more processing power that has like
this is a land party router for probably
like 10 people you could I think on most
any router you're right
just connect directly and stream while
everyone else because it's mainly about
upload but you can stream while everyone
else is doing normal stuff on the
internet so that's a very good question
Wi-Fi though the bigger the router the
better the router the better but it you
should be connected directly I didn't
mean for this to be a stream to twitch
talk tech Lahoma does stream to twitch
too so it is very relevant to OBS this
is mainly about the recording the
presentation part any other questions
no can always talk afterwards I really
like this because I'll use this YouTube
video to show my son so he can get
jumping and get started with OBS and
twitch pretty soon and I meant to kind
of do this for him just I think Kimberly
is really good at making me collect my
thoughts and learn so kind of learn you
know walk the walk the walk type of
thing and that's kind of what I did for
her all right thank you all and I'll be
here for a little bit to answer
questions thank you